take me back to the first day of Reddit
how did it start well so that that's I
can the first day of Rhetta is defined
in a couple ways the first day we got
into Y Combinator is probably the better
story yeah we were we were seniors in
college at UVA and we had planned on
University of Virginia University of
Virginia right we had planned on doing
another startup totally orthogonal to
Reddit
I didn't ordering food from cellphones
and not a bad idea
we've seen a come and go a couple times
it's never taken off it hasn't why it's
it's because you are selling to
restaurants and every local business you
have to come you know you have to have a
salesperson for every single restaurant
it doesn't scale very well it's like
open table across them it's a million
dollars yep is very difficult to get off
the ground an open table still isn't
used you know yeah it's only like five
or ten percent of the rest for exactly
so so you guys can that idea well so
that spring Spring Break Paul Graham was
giving a talk at Harvard called how to
start a startup that was a big Paul
Graham fan he had written you know he
had written all those essays online
glorifying startups and the via web
story and and programming and Lisp and
so I told Alexis oh look hey this this
programmer likes giving a talk and
Alexis was like let's go yeah so we went
on a spring right we met Paul got him to
sign my book he agreed to have dinner
with us and we told him our idea Socko
and food thing you know like that's a
great idea you should you should do that
that's great and we talked about it for
about an hour he loved it a few days
later we email them said hey thanks for
meeting up with us he's like hey I'm
starting this company called Y
Combinator to invest in early stage
startups you guys should apply and what
year is this
this is 2005 wow this is spring of 2005
we apply to Y Combinator they invite us
up for an interview we interview we get
rejected
we were so pissed we're like well what
the hell Paul like you said we were
getting in we were on the train right
back to Virginia and he called us and he
said you know we really like you guys we
just don't like that idea if you want to
work on something else come back and we
can figure out something else
Wow so I got off the train we're in the
middle of Connecticut got back on a
train going north
I met with Paul have this brainstorming
session and out of that
the beginnings of what would ultimately
turn into Retta